en los últimos años la temporada de
incendios en siberia empeoró este verano
más de 18 millones de hectáreas de los
bosques rusos se incendiaron el peor
daño desde que se tiene registro las
olas de calor son un factor clave para
que ardan las llamas en la región que se
extiende a ambos lados del círculo polar
ártico durante la ola de calor del año
pasado la ciudad de per collins alcanzó
38 grados celsius la temperatura más
alta registrada en el ártico por la
organización meteorológica mundial
y el calor que vimos en siberia en 2020
habría sido casi imposible sin el cambio
climático
rodgers de temperaturas de 38 grados
celsius en el ártico ya sabes realmente
indica que algo anda muy mal con el
clima además la agencia de la onu está
investigando otras temperaturas récord
incluido un posible máximo mundial de 54
grados celsius en el valle de la muerte
en california y una temperatura de casi
49 grados celsius en sicilia este verano
que podría ser la peor en europa
el ártico sin embargo se está calentando
dos veces más rápido que el resto del
planeta su hielo derretido amenaza la
vida silvestre aumenta el nivel del mar
libera grandes cantidades de metano un
gas de efecto invernadero y abre nuevas
áreas para posibles perforaciones de
petróleo y gas